[Music]
[Applause]
all right uh let me bring in Andy
Staples we always love talking to Andy
covers college football for uh Onre
Sports he was at the national title game
joins us from Houston your takeaway from
this game is
what Michigan was best team in the
country and they proved it I mean that
was a dominant performance eight yards a
carry on the ground round and and they
won the way they won all season so this
is uh you can say what you want I know
that there will be people who will go
back to the sign stealing stuff and
they'll say oh they
cheated look we've known about all that
stuff since before they had to play
their toughest games they showed over
this stretch that they were better than
everybody else and you know you can say
what you want I I don't think it's going
to diminish the shine on uh the rings on
those guys fingers okay but five years
from now mhm
by then the NCAA is going to get around
to maybe ruling on this maybe maybe the
Kansas case took longer than that the
Kansas basketball and so we we that's a
big maybe well USC as well took a long
time that was six years for that but you
know is there anything that anything
that is going to come out you think five
years from now that may taint this
National Championship or take this
Championship away when the NCAA finally
gets around to a ruling I don't know
that it's going to be more than what we
already know you know that that Conor
stallions had people going to games and
and filming the sideline which you know
people outside college football who if
you don't know that rule that people
can't go Scout Games in person don't
even understand why it's a rule it's a
cost cutting rule that got put in place
in the 90s so it's one of those things
that if you have to spend five minutes
explaining why anybody should even care
I don't think anybody's going to
care you know something that Michigan
does that I wonder if other teams are
going to do this is they huddle up so
there therefore there's no signal so you
know the school that is stealing signs
or did steal signs you can't steal their
signs because they huddle up and Nick
Sabin talked about that that it's a
whole different look for the defense
when you know you can kind of see what's
going to happen know there's less
adjustments now they huddle up nobody's
signaling in anything and I wonder if
more teams are going to do it well I
think more teams teams are going to go
to an electronic method of signaling in
plays that that's been against the rules
too but during the bowl season not the
playoff teams were allowed to do it if
both teams wanted to do it so there were
games where you saw some of them were
using a thing where the coach was
tapping it in on an iPad and the players
it would pop up on on something they had
on their bodies so it's probably going
to go to what more what the NFL does
maybe not exactly the way the NFL does
it but that's probably how they do the
signaling and it's not even going to
matter what happens next with Jim
Harbaugh
boy we talked to Warden Manuel the ad at
Michigan last night and it sounds like
he's prepared for for an onslaught of
NFL interest in Jim Harbaugh and the way
he put it is is why wouldn't you be
interested if you're an NFL team the guy
coached the NFL four years he went to
the NFC championship game three times he
went to the Super Bowl once so it it
makes perfect sense with all these
openings it does seem like that's an
itch that Harbaugh wants to scratch the
interview with the Vikings two years ago
talked to the Broncos last year so it
makes sense I I asked about it last
night he's like no I just want to enjoy
this but I I I do think I do think
that's coming you did ask him about if
he wants to entertain the NFL well so he
said he said he's allowed to sit at the
big person's table at the family dinners
now because Jack Harbaugh had an FCS
Championship a national championship
John Harbaugh has a Super Bowl and now
he's got a national title so they he can
sit at the big person's table I said I
said would you like to add a Super Bowl
to that list and he said I just want to
enjoy this which is a perfectly Fair
answer yeah it just feels like and I
thought win or lose he was going to go
back to the NFL just feels like you know
maybe and now he's even more attractive
to you know some of these owners who
were going I want somebody to come in
and establish a culture and Jim Harbaugh
brings a culture with him he has a style
we saw that and it's a style that's very
similar to what his brother has with the
Ravens and I'm sure Jim is going to want
to try to replicate that again and maybe
meet his brother you know in an AFC
title game or a Super Bowl yeah and
maybe the lights don't go out this time
and maybe they maybe they don't you they
finished seven yards short of the goal
line they they turned it over on down
seven yards short of the goal line in a
five-point game that's how close he was
so can you imagine being that close of
course you'd want to go back and do that
and oh by the way the Ravens are the
number one seed in the AFC so if you
like what John Harbaugh is doing and you
just watch what Jim Harbaugh did and
what he did with this team was was
pretty spectacular in terms of team
building and how they came together the
sign stealing stuff did nothing but make
them come together because everybody was
talking about them everybody was calling
them cheaters and they really rallied
around each other this was a group that
you know they were they were built to
dominate like this but it took that that
little extra where they came together I
think just helped them more it feels
like college football is similar to
NASCAR that you're cheating you're not
cheating until you get caught you're
always trying for an edge I I mean is is
that fair to have that big a blanket to
throw on the sport yes I think that's
that's fair and it's been a fair
assessment of the sport for over a 100
years so it they did get caught though
and there's a there's a kind of a code
among the people in college football
like don't be dumb enough to get caught
and they were all right um Michael penck
draft stock affected at all from last
night's
performance I think it might be a little
bit but more the than that the Medicals
are going to be what some teams are
going to look at because he had three
season ending injuries in Indiana and so
I think they they've got to figure out
okay do we feel like he can stay healthy
because if he can he still can throw
better than almost any quarterback in
this draft he and Caleb Williams are
probably in a class by themselves in
terms of just downfield accuracy uh but
last night yeah he he was pressing a
little bit I I talked to Brock hu last
week the the former Washington
quarterback and he said when he's
pressing he tends to miss high and
that's kind of what he did last night uh
five yards in attempt you know 255 yards
in in over 50 attempts is not an
efficient night and you saw there were
times when he had people open he had
romad dun open on that play that would
have probably changed the game and
overshot him so I mean that that's it
will affect it probably a little bit
because this is the best defense he's
played but I he's going to I believe
he's going to the Senior Bowl they're
going to see him up close And when they
see that ball come out of his hand
they're standing right there two feet
away they're going to go yeah there's
not many other guys doing that we're
talking to Andy Staples covers college
football for on three
Sports um I I'm not a college football
Insider uh but I think we got to move
the transfer portal after the bowl games
can we do that can we have a a better
window here that's a little bit more
fair to the bowl games you're going to
have more playoff games coming up next
year so you know these kids can maybe
play in those bowl games because they're
meaningful and then go into the transfer
portal it will take the coaches acting
like adults if they can handle it it can
be done the reason the transfer portal
window is where it is is because schools
go by semesters so that's when the
semester break is so if you're going to
enroll at your new school you're going
to enroll before the spring semester
starts so it can be done though I'll
give you an example last night if
Michael pennick had had to come out the
guy who would have come in is Dylan
Morris Dylan Morris is going to be James
Madison's quarterback next year but he
was still playing for
Washington so it was okay the world
didn't end because he suited up for
Washington last night and there were
other coaches who allowed their their
players to do this uh Eli dritz at
Missouri said hey look you can go on
visits you can decide where your new
school is going to be and you can come
play for us in the Cotton Bowl just as
long as it's not a distraction so it
definitely can be done but the the
coaches have to be the grown-ups about
it uh we say goodbye to the Pack 12 the
artist formerly known as the Pack 12 um
yeah you know I'm disappointed I I grew
up loving watching these games games
these
rivalries and you know now we have
Oregon State and Washington State the
two pack yeah at least they get to keep
all the money or at least most of the
money uh yeah it's it's very sad it's
just strange to see but that game last
night we saw was a big 10 game th those
two teams will be in the Big 10 and you
know I'm glad the Oregon Washington
rivalry gets ported to a new conference
and and USC UCLA but yeah that was a you
know identified that with the West Coast
it was West Coast Football uh you had
Pack 12 after dark it was its own
culture and the fact that the conference
was so badly mismanaged from Larry Scott
the previous commissioner to George
cleof the one who's there now it just
they just never quite understood the
business of college football or why
people care and how to make people care
and and they had a pretty good product
they just I don't think they understood
where it fit in
landscape great to talk to you thanks
for your contributions all season long
and uh thank you again thank you Dan
Andy Staples covers college football for
Onre Sports and I was there for the
national title game